Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome to Nuclear Power Plant Simulator
WHERE YOU, I'm assuming, play as a Homer Simpson type character in charge of way too many important s*it
Oh God.
I have no idea, what--- oh wow
Oh my God, there's so many buttons, so many lights..
"keep the lights green"
Oh God.
Well, that seems simply enough but maybe I should read the instructions.
Hello! "There are 3 reactors and a panel for each one.. Every reactor panel has 3 controllers:
"RED, core temperature; GREEN reduces the temperature and the reactor"
"increases the heat exchanger temperature""
"BLUE reduces the temperature--- OOHH MY GOD. (thank God he stopped reading so fast.)
"Find the perfect balance between these values to produce the amount of mega watts required."
"Figure out by yourself the best values you have---" BLAH BLAH BLAH
"Target: 150 MW"
"Produce less and you are fired. Produce more
and you are fired" Why produce more?!
Oooh God.
Okay.
"Routine Checks: You'll sometimes receive instructions...
Uuuhhh, "Do them within 40 seconds,
if you are late you something breaks...
AHHH S*IT. (NO.RLLY?!?!?)
"Boss-o-meter: I made the technical staff install an indicator on the 'Management' panel
that show how to being FIRED"?!
"It should be standard in every work station"?!
[tear filled laugh]
Oooohh my gooodddd...
Ooohh nooo booosss... :(
I don't want to disappoint you boss!
How do I get out of here?
Okay.
I don't know how to do this!
But I'll tryy...
Routine controls....
Habah dah, habah da. Habah da habah da!
BOINK!
Boink, boink!
Boink, boink.
(clicking noises)
UHm... this good, right?
CONFIRM! (buzzer noise)
AAaaahhh sh*t! I don't know how to do that!
Oh. There was flippy switches up top.
Ohoohhh god.
OOOOHHH! That's for that lateerr, okaay!
So we need to.... ump up some ump-age.
Oooo!
Ahhh, that's nice~
Ahhh, that's nice!
Okay.
Alright!
Is this good?
I dunno if this is good or bad...
The numbers seem to be exponentially increase!
Are they ever gonna stop?
Yeeeahhh, it seems okay
Except the reactor core seems to... be heating up, quite a bit.
Okay but that's good.
So, we each have individual three panels but they're all the same thing....
So long as I can kee- oop.
What's BEEPIN?!
IS THAT A BOMB?!
OH GOD.
Oh, hello!
Uuuhh... Oh. OH GOD.
Uhhh, bbb!
17.
Oh geez.
Ah geez.
Oh GOD.
Eeeeehhhh!
Eh!
What was that?
Let's see... "Down, down, down"
Down, down, down, down, down, down....
Was it one more down...? Yeah. One more down.
BOINK!
And then yellow... alright
Eeeeeehhhhhhhhhhhh
(clicking)
There we go!
YEAH!
What?! Did that not do it?
Oh god!
wAAAHHHH!!
WHY'S IT ON FIRE?!?!
I DIDN'T DO THAT!!!!!
Oooohhhhhhhh
Dooosssss oooonnn fire!
What do I do!?
UUUGGHHH, get the
GGUUUUUUHHH HUUUHHH!!!!!
Why is this on fire?!
Oohh god, it looks terrible out there.
Ooohhhh, I'm not doin-
Oohh SH*T!
God dammit!
What the f*ck was I supposed to do?!
"In case of fire, DEAL WITH IT"?!
Aaahh sh*t
Alright, let's try that again
That went terribly!
Ooohh, good golly.
Okay.
Let's try this again but a little less stuuupid.
VERY light!
Lots of coolin!
Gonna ramp up the coolants so it stays nice and cool~
I think that was my problem before like I was....
I wasn't doing enough cooling.
Cuz I gotta be mindful of that and
make sure the pressure doesn-
BuuuUUuuUuUuHHHHHHH
OH GEEZ! OH GEEZ!
Oh god! Oh god! Oh god!
EEEHHHEverything is fine!!!
EVERYTHING IS FIIINNE!!
Oh geez. Oh geez. Oh geeez.
Oh geez.
Ok.
No instructions YET.
Okay!
Everything is FINE!
EVERYTHING is hunky-dory!
Look at everything going over there!
Everything is great.
I love my job... :(
I love my life! :((
I love my job life.
Life-job.
please don't fire me..........
Uh huh! Uh huh!
UH. HUH!
O-KAY!
Whoooooooo!!
alright.
well that's looking a bit dangerous....
w-we need to amp up production a little bit.
oh geez.... oh geez, oh geez.
hhELLO!
45.
Alright! Down, down, down!
Uuuuuhhhhhhh-kay.
Oh! GOD dammit!
It's all wrong...!
Ah, sh*t
oohh god.
What was the red one's...?
Yeah, that was the red one.
(clicking)
BOINK! (ding!)
OKAY! GOT IT!
Got the instructions!
Everything looks good!
We need a lot more power or we're not doing enough!
Hoooly sh****t (sings)
HOOOOLY SH***T~ (sings)
So, heat exchange-r up-top and produuuu-
Oooooaahhh!!!
WHAT HAPPENED?!
AAHHHHH!!!!!!
WHAT THE HE-! WHA-HOW?!
How'd that fucking happen???
AAAHHHHH G-GET IT OUT!!!!!
(shrieking)
Oh god! Oh god! Oh god! Oh god!
Everything's fine! Everything's fine! Everything's fine. Okaaay, everything's fiiiiine.
Alrighty then!
Well, that sucked!
How the f*ck am I supposed to know what I'm doing???
Oh god...
ok.
Alright.
So we need to increase peeewer (power).
More peeeewer, more....
more coolant
more aaalllll- coolant
power. We can do more power.
We can do a lot more power. We're doing great!
We're doi- we're actually doing really good on power.
So everything is.....
Hhhhuunky-dory.
Ooooohh don't know why this is so goddamn flammable
Ooohh what was that?
Oh GOD! 185!
(hot moan)
(groaning)
precision! Okay.
BOINK! (ding)
Okay. Got it!
I'm good!
I'm smart, okay.
So, I'm not quite at my target, I need a little more.
I still need more....
need this....
coolant...!
Reactor core go up
quite a bit...
A little more.
A little more baby!
little more
Aaah, that might have been too much
aaAH!
Don't want too much!
Something gonna catch on fire?!
Kay, everything seems... green, green, green!
Green!
This is a lot more stressful than I imagined it would be.
OOoohhh, hahah-hi nuclear waste thing from the ceiling!
Okay but I think I have a better handle on this.
So, hopefully, you guys didn't see me panicking like a stupid idiot.
And now, I've got a better grasp on it!
okay, so this.... increase the cool-age a liittle bit more
THOSE...!!
Oh, cool it pleeease!
And theen....
I guess! OOOHHH!
I get it now!
Okay! So, the more I cool it, the
less heat is actually produced
and HEAT is actually what gets the powe- I've got too much, okat.
So, we need to knock it down a bit.
(alarm) Ooohh sh*t!
Oooohhhh god! Oh god!
BLLLUUUUUUHHHH HHUUURRR!!
Alright, blah bah ba- okay, we're good.
Alright.
So, I need to knock down the power a bit.
I can actually take this one down
WOAH! Hellooo, 205, you got it.
Twwwoooooo-oh-fiiiiiiivvveee
BOINK! (ding)
Got it!
Okay! Did a good.
Alright. Soooo, we're cloose
just gonna knock this down, just a little more...
this should work....
OR I can increase the coolant!
Which would prevent more heat from gettin-
(WHIP)
WHAT?! FIRED!!!??!
WHAT, FIIIIRREDDD??????
I WAS JUST GETTING IT!!!!!!
WHAT DO YOU MEAN FIRED?!?!?!
WHAT A BUNCH OF DIL-WEED HOLES!
WHAT A BUNCH OF JACK-BASTARDS!!
God dammit!!!
F*ck your anus!
Alright, fine!
I'll do this better....
Now, that I actually understand, this should bet a little better
Alright, alright, alriiiiiiggghhhttt
So, the secondary coolant can be like a direct connection to everything we need. 323.
three... eeeeehhh...
Okay, double green.
(clicking) Sh*t
Okay and then....
Oh, what were the flippies?
Just, one down.
You got it!
BOINK (ding)
Okay, so, we got this here
I'm gonna briiiing the secondary
cooling down even mooore
downing moore....
Down mmmooOOOOREEE.
Or... is that? That's dropping the power, so why?
OH!
WHHaat?
Wooaahhh
So, that's like a reeeeallly direct connec- WOAH SH*T!!!
WAAAH-WHATS ON FIRE?!?!
Eeerrrr, goddammit, not the instruction manual.
Okay, soo
Bringing this down or uuupp... oh geez
Why is bringing the coolant up make it more power?
Fascinating...
So, I have to make exactly 150, that seems....
ODDLY specific.
BOINK! (ding)
Okay, got it!
EEERRRRRRR BOSS-O-METER, I'M ABOUT TO BE FIRED!!
AAAAAAAAHHHHH I'M ABOUT TO BE FIRED!!!!!!!
I'm trying! It's just they're coming in on different levels!
Okay, I'm bringing up the reactor core.
Bringing up the reactor core!
AAAHHH, OH, WE'RE ON TARGET!
OH, STAY ON TARGET!!
STAY ON TARGET!!!!!
Oh, it's too muuch!!!
AAHH, it's too much!!!!
Too much!
Eh!
Go down! Down. Down.
NNNNNOOOOOOOO
THAT'S THE OPPOSITE OF WHAT I WANTED!!!!
Oh god, that was the opposite..
Eh!
(MANLY SHRIEKING)
AH GO DOWN!!!!!!
WHY'S IT GOING DOWN?
Why's it not going down!
Go down, dammit!
Suck a d*ck! Go down!!!!
AAHHH F*CK OFF!!!!!!!
EEEERRRRRRRAAAAA
I gotta beat this!
I gotta beat this.
I gotta beat this, go down.
Dammit! Go down.
Dammit. GOD dammit!
F*ck you! 352, god dammit.
(wrong buzzer)
What?! No!
Down, down, down, down.....
Ah, f*ck.
(ding)
Okay!
Wait, is this?
God DAMMIT! WHAT THE F****CCCK?
WHAT THE F*****CCCK??
Okay!
That go up! That stay up! And that stay do...
Yo-doooo, too much!
Ok.
stay RIGHT the F*CK there!
Yes!
YES!
YES!!!
Slay!
SLAY!!
Okay. Stay right the f*ck there!
Right on target!
Cuz Imma baller!
I know exactly what I'm doing, boss-o-meter!
Oh boi.
That LOOKS like I'm about to be fired but why would I be-duh (scats) fired?
Everything is good!
Everything is 100% good!
Am I out of time yet?
Ooohh geez.
(alarm)
Uuughh, sh*t, fire. F*cking fire.
Got it! Okay!
So, now that I got that, everything SEEMS to be nominal.
Raise up...
a little bit something else...
....little bit of something else...ok....
Hah-Ooooooookaaayy.
(ding) BOINK!
Okay! Got that!
Bleeeeehhh-NO! Why are we going down?!
Why are we going down? Why are we
going down? Why are we going down?
Why.
Why?
WHY?
Why ARE we going down!?
Don't go down!
Don't go down.
Don't be stuuuupid.
Aawh, boss-o-meter tell ya it looks better, I guess?
Looks... better...?
UUUHHH, STARTING TO PANIC.
OK! But we're doing good... okay!
I think we've actually got it under control now
because now that the power is being relatively nominal..
And everything seems to be green across the board...
I don't think we're gonna have any more problems and I don't think anything is gonna blow up (alarm)
OOOHHH GOD DAMMIT, THINGS ARE BLOWING UP.
F*cking.....
Oh f*ck..
Now, reactor core on 3 is being over-utilized.
Just number 3 for some reason is
being waay waaayyy overdone.
And I don't know what that MEANS and I don't know how to stop it but I think I only have 1 hour left....
So, if these guys hold out for one more
hour, then we're gonna be A-okay.
If everything can stop lighting oN FIIIRREE!
THAT'D BE LOVELY.
okay, we need to up...
(TRAIN WHISTLE BLOWS)
WOOOH! (accidental click) OH, GOD DAMMIT!!!!!!!!!
GOD DAAAMMIT!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!
WHAT THE FACK!
I didn't even get to READ what it SAID!!!!
I f*cking was already mid-click?!
GOD daaaammit!
FUCK! What did it SAAAAY?!
I don't even get to REEAD it!
Gaaahhhhhhhh.......
Put it up! Put it up!
Put up what it was!
OOHHH! THAT'S interesting information that I would've loved to have REEEEAAAAADDD.
Okay! But that was Power Plant Simulator
So... that was a bit of fun but it got a bit tedious after a while but still,
if you wanna reenact the life of Homer Simpson, feel free to play this game for yourself.
I-I'm actually surprised, this seemed only to be one level to it. I didn't know it'd be like that but either way!
Thank you everybody so much for watching!
And as always, I will see YOU in the next video.
BUH-BYE! <3
[outro theme]